Howdy!
We're Squid Research Lab,...
...your well-researched source for everything Splatoon.
So, what is Splatoon?
Let's start with this suspicious pool of ink that also hides a squid.
It's also kind of a humanoid.
Go into swim form to swim and sneak through ink,...
...then go from squid to kid and ink everything.
You're a kid, you're a squid.
You swim ink, you shoot ink.
Thems the basics of Splatoon.
Now, let's dive a little deeper, shall we?
Inklings have two legs, but bipedals can only go so fast.
So accelerate by letting those tentacles do the work in swim mode.
Leap out of ink and use momentum to get even more air.
Walls are also traversable as long as they are inked.
Verticality!
Use gyroscopic motion controls to aim your ink.
From there, it's essentially like using a water gun.
Aim, shoot.
Repeat.
You are now a certified squid movement specialist.